Vous vous ralliez à Jean la salle. Pourquoi lui ?
Parce que je pense que c'était de bon sens
et aussi quelqu'un qui a gardé des fortes
valeurs rurales.
Ça aurait été 1 erreur quand,
comme moi, je veux le faire avec mon équipe.
Et c'est trop de défendre 1 cause,
on fait attraction de ce qu'on est,
on fait attraction des postes des uns et des autres.
Nous on est là pour 1 cause,
la cause rural.
Lui aussi,
je pense que moi je voulais pas faire 1 liste
de toute façon,
avec des, avec des,
avec des gens qui avaient 1 étiquette politique,
des marqués ou des grands partis. Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça correspond pas.
Si j'avais voulu faire, je l'aurais fait.
On m'a proposé des tas de postes à chaque élection,
y compris l'élection européenne
par exemple.
Qu'est-ce qu'on vous a proposé ? Mais je vous demande,
je vous dirai pas Pierre devino,
pourquoi pas ? Parce que j'ai du respect,
parce que
vous pouvez imaginer qu'à peu près tout le monde,
sauf évidemment les écolo et les filles,
tout le monde, c'est-à-dire, j'ai des amis partout,
on a des amis partout, mais de droite comme de gauche